so would you mind doing a little true or
false on a few of the movies before okay
here we go first one
have you been to Skywalker Ranch yeah I
was there has George Lucas approached
you about playing Anakin Skywalker
approached keyword I you know we've
talked about it we've talked about you
know we've talked to me about it so I
don't know but there's no like script
yet or anything a long time ago so we'll
see would you consider it I'm not you
know how to consider it yeah I don't
know what I'm supposed to say when I'm
not supposed to say but you know are you
sure you want to do this only you want
to go to war with me Howard Hughes with
Michael Mann that is in development what
does that mean well development means
that the script is being written and a
lot of concentration and thought is
being put into the broad day and you're
considering yeah I mean I was I brought
it to Michael Mann and I thought it
would be an awesome I've always thought
that Howard Hughes was one of the most
fascinating genius
you know tortured individuals of all
time and I thought it would be such an
amazing character to play the life that
that man led I think you know can fit 50
lives into that guy's life so I thought
that that would be a real you know
interesting character to play what is
the downside of being king of the world
of doing Titanic king of the world
never leave that one up down I have sort
of adapted my life to this you sort of
have to adapt and move on to certain
situations you know I'm not gonna lie
and say that some things aren't
uncomfortable sometimes they absolutely
are but I really truly haven't changed
my my life that much as far as you know
going places that I want to go and doing
the things that I want to do you know I
everyone always talks about what it's
like but you know in everyday life you
sort of cocoon yourself within your
family and friends and you do you that
that's your life you know what I mean it
isn't necessarily going on like world
tours and you know meeting millions of
different people it's you know living at
home in their house and driving your car
to wherever and doing this in that and
and sometimes there's weird situations
but you adapt and you then you make the
best of it and for all the you know
great things that it's given me it's
completely worth it you know acting me
it's trade-offs with everything in life
you know but uh you know it's giving me
the opportunity in life to really you
know acting and being an actor is
something that the only sure thing that
I've always known throughout my entire
life so it's given me so many more
opportunities and so much more than I
can ever hope for that it's completely
worth it the only thing you could sort
of control is you know that I can sort
of control is what I want to do as an
actor you know what I mean where I want
to go with my career and that's what I
can control and there's certain things
that you have to take with a grain of
salt and and just sort of let happen you
know what I mean because the more you
try and fight in order to rebut things
that are said about you or whatever it
only feeds the problem and only makes
the problem bigger I think
I mean I'm of that school of thinking
that
the truth about a person sort of comes
out in the end or whatever I think I
think so yeah I think so I mean
eventually who you are as a person is
reflected through your work you know
it's so much success and everything that
comes with it how do you decide who you
trust and who you surround yourself with
that's it's a process of elimination in
life - you know what I mean you do you
think a lot of times you meet people and
you think that wow this is a real
genuine kind you know endearing person
but then you gotta sort of ask myself
why they interested in being friends
with me you know why you have to ask
yourself that question but you know it's
sort of a cliche at this point I think a
lot of people in the entertainment
industry have said this a lot but you
know I have a good solid group of you
know friends that I've known for a long
time that you know I trust with my life
you know and that's good that's good you
know even though I've sort of grown up
in Los Angeles and you know I was born
in Hollywood for God's sake you know I
have found a you know a tight group of
friends that I'm able to rely on for
everything and that hasn't that has
throughout anything changed whatsoever